ah what of you the air over here is
especially wait what is this doing here
this is what if and here's what would
happen if another planet smashed into
Earth about 50 billion rogue planets are
roaming the Milky Way with no host star
to hold on to
they don't give off any light of their
own and that makes them difficult to
spot last time a stray planetoid the
size of Mars smashed into Earth it
scattered our planets young crust into
space where gravity glued those
particles into what we now call the moon
this time it would be all Hellfire and
brimstone
with no survivors left and here's a
timeline of how things break down a few
weeks before the collision an unknown
object would appear in the sky it
wouldn't happen overnight no we know
something was coming we'd see the
planets slowly growing bigger until one
day it was as big as the moon it would
seem as if everything was unfolding in a
relatively slow pace but that's only
because of the huge distances involved
out there in space the rogue planet
would rush towards us at a speed of 11
kilometers a second when the uninvited
space intruder came into the moon's
orbit bad things would start to happen
the gravitational pull of the alien
planet would make the tides on earth
eight times larger than they are now
floods would begin to wrap it through
the coastline cities and still the
megatsunamis are yet to come
28 hours before the collision the
gravity of both planets pulling
themselves towards each other would
speed up the process the incoming planet
would hit a speed of 60 kilometers a
second megatsunamis would plot their way
across the oceans with this would come
lightning storms plus hurricanes and
tornadoes so large they wouldn't have a
number on the category scale if you
didn't book yourself a vacation aboard a
spaceship that would take you to outer
space your time on this planet would be
running out three minutes before the
collision the rogue planet enters the
Earth's atmosphere provided you hadn't
already been killed by the lightning
hurricanes flooding earthquakes or
volcanoes you'd see the rocky invader
completely filling the sky above you
nano seconds before the collision the
atmospheres of both planets would be
compressed together and glow brightly it
would get so hot that everything on the
side of the earth about to get hit would
instantly vaporize for the rest of the
earth the ground would become scorching
magma
[Music]
upon impact the collision would cause
friction between the two planets
millions of tons of superheated rock
would be sending a wall of fire in all
directions while the Hellfire would rush
across Earth's surface the planets inner
core would be melting it from the inside
out this would have one big outcome the
earth would collapse in on itself the
end of the era if you did manage to get
away in a spaceship you'd see the
massive remnants of both planets
catapulted into different orbits some of
them would hit other planets others
would be fired out of the solar system
entirely whatever was left would form a
new asteroid belt encircling the Sun
none of this would give any hint that
there was once intelligent life on
planet Earth but hey you can sleep well
knowing that this will never happen well
most likely not in any case you've got
time to watch a few more what-ifs
[Music]
Oh
[Music]